In this video, we'll explore the modeling tools available to us in Unreal Engine, which
can help to adjust geometry that needs further changes after a Datasmith import.
Sometimes, your scene may need to be readjusted in your DCC application, then re-imported
into Unreal as a Datasmith file.
Other times, you may find it makes more sense to make the adjustment directly in Unreal Engine.
The Modeling Tools plugin is a good friend for this.
It allows us to repair or adjust meshes without going back to our DCC application and do
things such as selecting triangles individually, by material, by element, or by smoothing groups.
We can change pivot point placement, we can delete or flip faces, we can adjust UVs, and
we can even add material elements or sub-materials to any set of selected triangles.
In order to use the Modeling Tools plugin, it simply has to be enabled as the Modeling
Tools Editor mode.
You'll also find other editor modes, such as for hair, static meshes, and even skeletal
meshes, but they will not be covered in this course.
To enact minor mesh repairs, simply select and edit faces using the variety of face
selection parameters available to you.
From there, you'll see common model actions, such as extrude, inset, delete, and flip if
you want to change the normals.
If you plan on acting on the same groups of geometry several times, you can create polygroups
for easier reselection.
Also note the ability to easily relocate pivot points based on simple selections of the overall
position relative to the mesh.
To briefly demonstrate modeling mode, let's go ahead and open up that Modern House Datasmith
map, select any object you like, go to the drop-down here and select Modeling, which
can also be found with Shift 5, and then we're presented with a cornucopia of different tools,
creating fresh geometry.
Briefly, let's go ahead and click Select and Try Select, just to see that we're able
to grab services here.
There's the ability to create a polygroup if we've got a selection we plan on reusing
quite a bit, and if we go down to Deform, we can see a quick example of Offset.
In case we want an easy way to change that geometry, we have tools like Displace, which
with a higher subdivision of triangles could start to add a lot more variation to the geometry
here if we wanted to feel a little less orthographic.
Finally, let's just take a look over in X-Form and Edit Pivot.
We'll notice that in this scene, all of the objects came in with their pivot point over
here, which is 0, 0, 0, in the original project the Datasmith file came from, but we might
want to reuse some of this geometry or just have easier access to adjust it, and here
we could click on something like Center to bring the pivot point here.
If we wanted to stay on the ground, we could click Bottom, and if we don't like how far
underground that is, we could go and start to adjust that manually.
We could go and start to bring this up until this is at 0.
As this transform is specific to the pivot point, once I press Accept, I now have a pivot
point much more usable for this particular piece of geometry.
In the next video, we'll look at collisions.